la orquestra k luz de ucrania pretende
levantar el ánimo de sus compatriotas
ucranianos con una victoria
su canción stefan es interpretada en
ucraniano y fusiona el rap con música
folclórica tradicional las casas de
apuestas la han convertido en la clara
favorita de la ocasión estefanía fue
escrita mucho antes de que estallara la
guerra estaba dedicada a mi madre pero
después de que empezara la guerra la
gente le dio un nuevo significado porque
piensan en la madrugá nea por eso está
tan cerca del corazón de muchos
ucranianos a muchos europeos también les
gustaba el cine europa rusia está
excluida debido a la guerra en ucrania
los fans de eurovisión están en la
ciudad anfitriona de touring para gritar
por su favorito entre los 25 finalistas
[Música]
no no no
medita
[Música]
pide trabajo bien estaba bien y trabajo
mi trabajo
estos aficionados franceses consideran
que serbia tiene la mejor conexión con
este tema de la cantante contracto
[Aplausos]
la decisión final en eurovisión se
divide entre un jurado profesional y el
público
y su clan hagan a estocolmo se ha
ofrecido a acoger el evento del año
próximo en el caso de que la guerra
continúe
[Aplausos]